finding an affordable rental proven to
be more and more difficult these days
thank you for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez a
recent report shows the valley has some
of the highest rent increases in the
country joe moeller spoke to renters and
he's live at spring mountain valley view
with more on that report joe
well people remember when you could
spend a thousand to 1200 bucks and get a
decent rental these just right here just
a few hundred bucks even more than that
according to the website and that's 401
bedroom people say finding a nice rental
is getting more difficult than the
prices are forcing some to look
elsewhere
the cheapest i found right now is like
1800. amanda justice is one of many
renters stuck trying to find an
affordable place finding a three bedroom
on her budget is not easy the prices
that i see like
i don't see it matching the place that
they're renting it for a recent report
from apartment guide shows rent is up in
henderson 45 percent from a year ago the
vegas area is near the top of many
rental increase lists we have a housing
shortage which also means we have a
rental shortage real estate agent trish
nash says it is easy to spot new
apartment complexes going up because the
demand is there i jumped on zillow to
compare newer two-bedroom apartments
across the valley what i saw was similar
apartments would cost one thousand six
hundred and sixty dollars in the
northwest 1850 in the southwest upwards
of seventeen hundred dollars in
henderson and the most affordable area
being the northeast at around fourteen
eighty-five so really it's what
what will the market bear and a lot of
owners out there a lot of investors are
putting a high price just to see you
know can i really get twenty four
hundred dollars she says many are not
finding what they want if i could be
back in a heartbeat i would joyce hamlin
moved to utah last week after looking
for two months in vegas she says prices
and availability forced her out we
desperately needed something and this
was the first one so we just had to load
up and move
now back out here live we took this
topic to social media even doing a
facebook live earlier many people say
when their leases ended they were forced
to pay several hundred dollars more they
say a more difficult part is trying to
find another place here in las vegas
right now so many people just staying
put and forced to pay extra money
reporting live joe mohler live local now